Ah, here it is.
Yeah. There is a leak.
So strange he didn't tell you.
That's not really.
You know, in my experience.
Husbands don't keep that many things
secret from their wives, you know?
Mmm. Right.
You guys tell each other everything.
Till death do you part.
Hey, Ava?
How long do you want me to keep this up?
What? You're really going to make me
keep looking for the fake leak?
So.
Here's what I think happened.
I think you figured out the whole
thing. The booties.
The scratches.
Pomona. All of it.
There's no way our sweet Nathan put all
that together himself.
He's not wired like us.
I think you came up with this podcast.
No idea what you're talking about.
Okay. Here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to give you one more chance
to tell me the truth, because if this
is going to work, if we're going to
move forward as partners, there's got
to be trust. Am I right?
So what's it going to be?
It's Ava, leave a message. Hey, it's me
again. Just call me when you get this,
okay? He's still not here.
I don't know where you are.
Just. Just call me.
You're late.
Yeah, I brought a friend.